demi lovato opens up about life after
her near-fatal overdose and why she's
not completely sober i think the term
that i best
identify with is california sober
so what does that mean the 28 year old
says she still drinks and smokes
marijuana in moderation
i feel the complete abstinent method
isn't like a one-size-fits-all solution
for everybody
in spite of demi's disclaimer addiction
expert ken seely says
her parameters are highly dangerous to
tell people that they could be
sober and use in moderation is
almost criminal because i guarantee you
if that takes off
people will die thinking that they're
california sober
lovato od'd on heroin in 2018 and
reveals to cbs sunday morning
how close she came to dying the doctors
um told me that i had
five to ten minutes and before like if
no one had found me
then i wouldn't be here basically i woke
up in the hospital and i was legally
blind
so i literally couldn't see the od
strokes caused brain damage the singer's
youtube docu-series dancing with the
devil
debuts tomorrow it's a deep dive into
her addictions and past eating disorder
but she says today she's finally got
control of her life back
every time i was in a hotel room my
phone was taken out of the room so i
couldn't order room service
i'm now in control of my finances i'm
now in control of
the food that i eat how often i work out
i think it's a really slippery slope
for her and i only pray that something
bad doesn't happen
praying that she gives back the control
to somebody
that could really help her you know at
the end of the day you just want her to
be happy
healthy and win that war with her
sobriety
all right now this is a four-part
docu-series so expect more shocking
revelations coming very soon
every time i think something can't shock
me anymore in hollywood it does